son qu'on se pose ce soir c'est si le
président a entendu les maires vous avez
pu le suivre sur figaro live
j'ai tant appris des débats que nous
avons eus ensemble je vous promet un
nouvel aménagement du territoire et de
recoudre une france déchirée c'est ce
qu'a notamment déclaré en substance le
chef de l'état en débrief avec vous et
avec vos invités
on s'intéressera aussi à la démarche du
président qui fait aujourd'hui un
discours et demain une réception en
grande pompe à l'elysée à l'elysée alors
n'est ce que de la coop ou un
retournement de la part d'un dirigeant
qui avait élevé et les maires l'an
dernier on vous pose la question on en
débat on jettera un coup d'oeil
également sur la situation dans les facs
ont jours après l'immolation d'un
étudiant devant le crous de rennes
frédéric vidal un ministre
d'enseignement supérieur refuse
d'augmenter les bourses comme le
demandaient les syndicats étudiants mais
octroie la gratuité pendant l'hiver aux
étudiants qui ne payent pas leur loyer
au crous un téléphone vert pour
connaître toutes les aides et un statut
pour les militants associatifs
est ce une bonne idée est ce trop ou pas
assez on en débat vous avez été nombreux
aussi à lire et commenter nos infos sur
le dernier rapport de la cour des
comptes sur la sncf sureffectif rigidité
déficit alors quels remèdes pour les
mots qui ont été cités j'attends vos
solutions ou à tout le moins vos
suggestions puis on ira comme le grand j
à vesoul une religion une religieuse
pardon s'est vu interdire l'autorisation
de vivre en habit avec son voile dans
une maison de retraite gérée par la
commune le directeur avec le règlement
et la laïcité le curé lui en colère et
le maire dans l'embarras et vous qu'en
pensez-vous on en débat mais on va
justement s'intéresser
aux autres maires ceux qui sont réunis
au palais des expositions à la porte de
versailles avec emmanuel macron j'ai
fait ce que j'ai dit c'est ainsi que le
président de la république a commencé à
s'adresser tout à l'heure aux édiles
j'ai beaucoup appris a notamment déclaré
confessé le chef de l'état j'ai beaucoup
appris du grand débat on l'écouté je ne
suis certes pas maire d'une commune de
france mais je me sens chaque jour un
peu plus à votre contact maire de la
commune france c'est à dire à la fois
gardien de l'essentiel l'unité de la
nation et du quotidien concret des vies
alors emmanuel macron n'a pas fait de
grande annonce aujourd'hui en tous les
cas jusqu'à présent est ce que néanmoins
le peu que vous en avez entendu vous
avez appris des choses brics couturier
oui j'ai appris j'ai appris que ma kron
avait été coincé dans l'image de l'homme
de grands centres urbains à l'image
quand il a construit lui qu'un enfant de
picardie après tout on a construit
l'image que c'était quelqu'un des
grandes métropoles urbaines si vous
voulez si on reprend la fameuse
terminologie david good heart qui oppose
le peuple de quelque part et les gens de
n'importe où on a fait de macron une
espèce vers incarnation de ses jambes
n'importe où à l'aise partout à travers
le monde sans racines profondes etc
c'est très faux parce qu'encore une fois
c'est certain c'est un gamin damien
c'est pas un parisien signe amiens
banlieusards mais c'est vrai que on a eu
le sentiment au début de mandat
peut-être parce qu'il sait laisser
coincer dans ce rôle que il était le
représentant des élites métropolitaine
il a réagit déjà contre cette image
quand il l'a fait il a initié le grand
débat souvenez vous au grand
bourgtheroulde c'était d'une belle image
c'était une façon de dire qu'il était
qui cherchait effectivement une
incarnation effectivement comme il le
dit il a jamais été maire il n'a pas
fait le cursus honorum de la classe
politique habituelle qui passe par une
grande mairie puis par le la députation
et enfin où la présence d'une région
puis enfin la présence de république il
a sauté toutes ces cases il est arrivé
directement ce qui fait qu'il était
assez mal vu arrêté par le milieu d'eux
des grands élus de nos grands élus il
est il a renoué avec le plaisir à la
france profonde à travers les mers lors
du grand débat c'était évident c'est par
eux qui s'est adressé à cette france
périphérique paysanne pour renouer avec
le pays profond moi je pense qu'il avait
déjà réussi à l'époque du grand ben du
grand débat et que le retour auprès des
maires finalement c'est le deuxième
deuxième acte il a il a réussi sept
il a réussi à casser cette image de
président cosmopolite est loin des élus
locaux
parce que pour le gars il faut se
rappeler macron c'était le président
verticale il utilisait il manque un roi
à la france de la france jamet il y
incarnait cette espèce de verticalité
quasi monarchique au début c'est vrai
vous avez besoin
il n'avait pas suivi le cursus honorum
mais il s'en vantait il reprochait aux
autres de l'avoir suivi en disant mais
tout ça c'est de l'immobilisme du passé
du conservatisme tous ces élus qui font
leur cuisine dans le petit coin
moi je ne suis pas de cette espèce là
qui en fait je suis de la combine
politicienne je vais trancher dans le
vif et donc là maintenant il se dit il
devient maire lui même il devient maire
de la commune france quand on arrête
vous qu'on avait commencé comme roi de
france et on finit maire de la commune
france sa peau d'âne immense effort sur
soi même je ris mais en même temps c'est
pas inutile c'est vrai que ce qui lui a
été beaucoup reproché ses sept c'est un
côté un peu dédaigneux méprisant avec la
ruralité avec la france périphérique
avec toutes ces vieilles formes de la
vieille démocratie représentative dont
qui se donne du mal donc on peut dire ah
c'est un peu caricatural ces deux là
comme moi ça veut dire qu'il a compris
c'est à dire qu'il a compris qu'ils
pouvaient pas continuer comme ça c'est
déjà je pense que le grand enseignement
de la sphère des gilets jaunes esprit
c'est qu'il a compris qu'elle sorte de
choses ne passait pas donc ils se
donnent du mal pour changer après ce qui
change au fond de lui ça c'est une autre
question philosophique est ce qu'un
homme une charge au fond de lui c'est
une autre affaire en tout cas en
politique déjà quand on se comporte
différemment
c'est le début du changement alors avant
d'avoir le débat philosophique on peut
d'ailleurs l'engager avec voice
couturier qui s'est intéressé à mâcon
philosophe je vous propose d'écouter
justement cet échange qui a eu lieu avec
enfin à tribunes interposées avec
françois baroin autour d'une mesure
phare du quinquennat
macron la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation
c'est un fruit qui passe pas très bien
un goût amer il reste un peu en travers
de la gorge la digestion est délicate
elle est à peine engagé
nous vous tiendrons naturellement
informés de l'évolution de ce bol
alimentaire
nous souhaitons d'ailleurs en quelque
sorte partager l'évolution inscrite dans
la durée
comme tous les chefs d'états et vous
n'êtes pas le premier vous avez décidé
de supprimer un impôt qui vous
appartient pas
[Applaudissements]
alors avantage baroin à l'applaudimètre
à ce moment-là de l' échange on écoute
la réponse d'emmanuel macro sur la taxe
d'habitation c'est durant votre campagne
beaucoup de vos électeurs vous reproche
la baisse faites le moi savoir
et qu'il vient se plaindre et parfois
peut-être vous aurez le droit d'empocher
les félicitations qu'il vous livre à
vous et pas au gouvernement parce que
c'est ce qui va vous arriver
alors il a tort et la raison de prendre
comme ça non ce qui est frappant c'est
que ça hyper français cette espèce des
changes de bons mots et à qui gagnera
l'art du plaidoyer l'art oratoire après
tout la question pour mac ronces et par
rapport aux municipales et il tomba
d'hormones non mais les femmes ont
désormais elles aussi bon donc on verra
ce qui se passe en anglais brillait les
mois mais toute la question toute la
question c'est au fond que la emmanuel
macron parle des échéances électorales
et au fond il vient dire est ce que
c'est vous qui allez gagner ou est ce
que c'est moi est quelque part ils
montrent que la république en marche est
aujourd'hui devant une échéance
importante qui au fond de se structurer
au niveau des municipalités à travers
ces élections qui sont en général peu
favorable au pouvoir en place
et comme vous venez le rappeler vincent
la république en marche ne s'est pas
structurée autour des élections locales
jusqu'à présent je rappelle que c'est un
parti politique on pouvait s'inscrire
sur internet et être membre d'un autre
parti politique est aujourd'hui je gagne
les élections de juste le tube oui mais
c'est différent c'est assez différent
ils ont gagné les élections législatives
parce que maintenant il ya un alignement
du calendrier est donc on donne majorité
au président s'est elle a perdu son
caractère mixte qui étaient locales et
nationales à la fois l'élection
législative donc ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que jusqu'à présent au fond
emmanuel macron à déléguer à des
personnes qui venaient plutôt de la
droite des républicains
edouard philippe sébastien lecornu qui
eux étaient mer et qui étaient élus
locaux il leur a délégué en quelque
sorte le fait d'être au sein de la
république en marche ce qu'ils
organisaient
la relation avec les collectifs le
territoire est là pour pour les
échéances qui viennent il fait un pari
d'abord il a des mères les républicains
qui se sont ralliés ensuite il investit
de nouveau candidat donc il refait le
coup de je me structure à partir du rien
et donc ce qui est très intéressant c
est ce que ce sont quelque part des
vieux de la vieille qui vont gagner
l'échéance municipale ou est ce que
c'est des nouveaux est ce que par
exemple il a fait par exemple paris de
mettre beaucoup plus de femmes têtes de
listes que dans les vieux partis parce
que il a la latitude de le faire parce
qu'il a peu de mer avec lui il a peu
d'élus locaux
donc je crois que ce qui est intéressant
là dedans c'est que certes il va se
faire apprécier des mères en place mais
quelque part
le sujet c'est au fond la conquête on
peut dire qu'il ya deux choses qui sont
devant nous et la deuxième chose que je
veux dire c'est que emmanuel macron n'a
jamais fait tellement le collectif il a
derrière lui des gens qui le suivent
mais c'est un chef est ce qu'il va être
capable à partir de cette question
territoriale de cette adresse à des à
des personnes qui ne leur semble pas de
structure et plus de collectif dans la
vie politique c'est aussi ça c'est aussi
ça la vie politique c'est si on veut
s'organiser dans le futur il faut avoir
avec soi des gens qui vous qui vous
suivent et françois baroin là il assure
à l'applaudimètre le fait que tout le
monde est d'accord avec lui dans la
salle sur la question une question qui
est importante qui est la question des
listes communautaire sur laquelle le
président est revenu justement tout à
l'heure il a déclaré que lui n'était pas
en pleine favorables à son interdiction
alors l'interdiction mais qui promettait
des mesures dans les prochaines semaines
de la part du gouvernement
c'est quand même le signe qu'il entend
quand même les maires et notamment cet
appel qui a été lancée dans l'éclusé ce
week end dans le journal du dimanche par
une certaine un certain nombre de maires
nous avons sur le problème de ce qu'ils
ont appelé le vivre ensemble qui ont qui
était également sur les sur sur ces
questions là les questions de sécurité
ce qu'il faut voir
lucie la raison il ya deux questions la
première c'est qu'en effet la date n'est
pas indifférente c'est bientôt les
élections municipales et donc ils
recherchent un air un enracinement qui
pour le moment est le dernier bien c'est
juste dire qu'il appartient aux élèves
la deuxième de la deuxième chose c'est
que les mères restent encore le corps
intermédiaires qui n'est pas démonétisé
aux yeux des français un accès larcher
qui disait c'est celui qui a apporté une
baffe et c'est peut-être pour ça qu'on
est encore attaché
néanmoins ils rencontrent d'énormes
problèmes et j'en viens à votre question
les maires actuellement c'est quand même
une vie et une fonction crise puisque de
nombreux maires ne souhaite pas se se
représenter je cite un autre maire choix
que ces mères d'argent sont gelés noter
que j'entends pardon j'ai noté quelque
part dans l'orne qu'ils aient tous mère
un fils en prison le tout c'est de ne
pas mettre l'autre ayant c'est un sujet
je crois qui a été abordé au cours de
ces journées
donc là il leur fait un petit peu de de
calinothérapie mais il ya en effet
d'énormes problèmes dont celui du vivre
ensemble comme on le dit communément
maintenant qui est que rencontre par
exemple les mères de la france
périphérique de façon évidente c'est à
dire que les centres villes se vident et
guy lui l'a très bien décrit on
s'imagine qu'on va pouvoir remplacer de
façon tout à fait neutre une population
locale historique qui est partie par une
population de migrants avec des
communautés différentes qui doivent
cohabiter en imaginant que ça ne fera
pas de différence donc évidemment ça
c'est parce qu'il avait un vrai sujet
c'est parce qu'il a dit ceci du jour
d'ardents sais pas ce qu'il a dit non
mais c'est quand même le problème que
rencontrent les maires de fait dans leur
commune alors il a dix qui se
préoccuperait des dix communautaire moi
ce qui m'ennuie un petit peu en tout cas
il a il a fait mine d'évoquer le sujet
ce qui m'ennuie un petit peu c'est que
il en va de ce sujet comme de
l'immigration en réalité il n'ya pas
tellement de deux solutions juridiques
d'ailleurs je dirais que si certaines
moeurs certains maires sont ennuyés par
les listes communautaire c'est aussi
parce que certains maires qui dans ces
listes peuvent voir une partie de leurs
en étant cynique une partie de leurs
torts à fuir vers ses disques
communautaire
mais j'ai bien peur que là aussi on en
reste aux mots et aux je vous ai compris
non suivies d'effet il a dit très
clairement qui aurait pas d'interdiction
oui il a même rigolé vous croyez que les
islamistes vont arriver en disant moi je
suis islamistes vais faire dix
islamistes donc il était très clair et
faisant il peut pas il peut pas alors la
vraie question est là la vraie question
est là je pense qu'un certain nombre
d'arguments juridiques s'est soudain
possibilité me semble t'il pratique pour
le faire parce que comment on fait pour
précisément comment reconnaître
juridiquement ici on peut trouver dans
la constitution d'un jury séance du
conseil constitutionnel et shottle
l'ancien secrétaire général du conseil
fonctionnel fait un papier assez
convaincant là dessus en disant
juridiquement on pourrait mais sauf que
si pratiquement on peut pas on comment
fais tu là seul truc que je comprends
pas c'est pourquoi à ce moment là
puisque on ne décide pas le faire et que
c'est impossible pourquoi est-ce que
castanet reçoit retailleau et xavier
bertrand en installant le sujet donnant
le sentiment qu'on va le faire
permettant deux ans de sortir de ça on a
été entendu
c'était pas la peine il valait mieux pas
ce jeu en termes de gestion de ce sujet
pourquoi mettre le doigt sur des
problèmes parce que c'est malgré tout un
problème soit parce qu'on peut pas le
faire qu'il n'y a pas de problème
pourquoi mettre le doigt sur un problème
pour finir par dire on ne résoudra pas
je ne comprends pas bien même un élément
jeu rebondir sur ce que 10 à gabriel
c'est à dire que quand on a été élu
local ce qui est mon cas on sait de
longue date qui effectivement il ya une
gestion clientéliste des communautés et
que de toute façon elle et elle existe à
droite et à gauche et peut-être la
république en mai je sais pas encore et
donc toute la question c'est aujourd'hui
cette espèce d'indignation elle qui en
fait à l'émancipation des communautés
qui disent nous on va pouvoir se
débrouiller seul
donc il faut aussi s'apercevoir de la
manière dont on a nourri à bas bruit
certains phénomènes brice je reviens à
je rebondis sur ce qu'on vient
d'entendre
il ya 7 commentaires d'ailleurs de
nicole surre sur le chat du figaro qui
que elle trouve des chez lui des
envolées lyriques mais creuse et
démagogique c'est son commentaire mais
est ce que finalement quand on entend le
président on n'a pas quand même un
commentaire de la situation description
de la situation
et quant au plan d'action qui sont
évoqués par le président il n'y a rien
de nouveau dans ce qu'il annonce sauf
des choses qui ont déjà été entreprises
et même très concrètes
effectivement le plan d'action coeur de
ville l'agenda rural l'installation de
france est restée déjà des mesures qui
ont été déjà prises donc
paris devance hollande là quelqu'un qui
commentent mais qui ne fait rien mais je
vous parle de macron macron
effectivement c'est que quelque chose
est claire c'est fini l'époque où le
président a été cliqué qui convoquait
les poteries journaliste chez lui pour
lui dire que les tout allait mal en
france il comprenait pas pourquoi
non on l'a on a quand vous parlez tout
simplement de l'action en coeur de ville
on vient à l'instant de dire que les
centre-ville était en train en voie de
désertification parce que il ya des
mollahs l'américaine qui sont créées à
dans leur périphérie
l'action coeur de ville c'est
effectivement une façon de rendre de
revivifier à travers beaucoup d'argent
beaucoup d'argent des centaines de
millions pour faire en sorte que les
centres villes retrouvent une vitalité
et puis les maisons de services publics
fassent appel des maisons france
services qui sont kivu qui sans qu'ils
font revenir les services publics dans
les villes dans les petites villes de
l'est petit bourg de village vous vous
aurez à la fois les caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie les caisses assura
la vieillesse vous aurez les impôts vous
aurez la justice le ministère de
l'intérieur a aussi un représentant
c'est une façon de rené des mises est de
faire revenir des services publics dans
des endroits qui étaient en train envoie
des afghans qu'il est passé à l'acte
l'importance de pratiquer des coeurs de
ville ce qui est certes très importante
mais sur les sujets dont on parle à
l'instant communautarisme système
radicalisme politique forcé mal est de
constater qu'ils en parlent beaucoup et
même tout le temps même parfois un peu à
tort et à travers et qu'ensuite il ya
pas grand chose il n'y a rien de très
nouveau
il nous a refait là encore faisait douze
minutes culte fermer les quatre écoles
fermées les 120 débits de boissons ça
fait deux ans qu'ils nous fait les
quatre écoles
non non on n'est pas obligé par et tout
le temps des choses pour nous c'est à
dire sur l'intégration il fait pas non
parce que je pense que c'est un parti
pris psychologique il se dit qu'en
levant un tabou et en laissant les gens
s'exprimer ça fera des gens intéressants
comme une soupape de sécurité on n'en
parlera pas ce qu'il imagine que c'est
le sait le tabou qui suscitent la
rancoeur et rien n'a été réglé
le père de réponse et après on ne parle
aussi intéressante c'est quand macron
dit moi je suis responsable de la
commune france et on peut se dire que
c'est du lyrisme de pacotille moi je
trouve ça intéressant de dire qu'au fond
entre les problèmes nationaux et ce qui
se passe au niveau local il ya au fond
les mêmes sujets et c'est ça qui est
très intéressant sur la question de la
communauté ou du communautarisme lucide
pardonnez moi je vous coupe mais c'est
ce que disait un internaute du fidae
rocchi qui commentait tout à l'heure
elle a priori qui commentait tout à
l'heure il faut pas lire et commenter
les tout à l'heure le discours d'
emmanuel macron mais ça quand même
il vient de le découvrir que des
problèmes locaux pouvaient avoir des
résonances nationale c'est parce que les
problèmes nationaux
mais c'est localement je sais pas s'il
vient de le découvrir mais en tout cas
c'est peut-être le président de la
république qui le dit le plus clairement
c'est à dire que d'habitude on disait
toujours bon on s'adresse à des élus
locaux dont on parle des questions
locales avec un langage local et là il
parle d'une manière peut-être
exagérément schématique ou abstraites ou
philosophiques et il fait le lien entre
les différentes échelles et moi je pense
que c'est essentiel je ne dis pas que je
suis d'accord avec emmanuel macron
surtout mais l'idée de faire le lien
entre les échelles entre le local et le
national ça je pense et l'européen ça je
pense qu'on peut lui porter crédit là
dessus alors la question les maires at
il été entendu par emmanuel macron là
c'est non à 73% en tant qu'application
que on faisait sur twitter et elle lancé
il y aura également une question du
figaro sur la question sur juste brise
sur ce que disait gabriel tout à l'heure
sur le fait que
une stratégie chez emmanuel macron de
pouvoir de dénoncer les choses mais sans
les sens les crédits pour pouvoir non je
vécu et je viens je suis pas d'accord je
pensais pas une soupape de sécurité je
pense que c'est non on va voir chacun a
ses partis pris je pense que vous avez
non j'ai quand même le sentiment que il
s'agit effectivement de permettre le
débat public d'ouvrir le débat public
après lequel il y aura une manière de
trancher sur le plan politique
évidemment mais on a déjà commencé quand
on nous dit que s'il n'y a rien sur
l'immigration c'est complètement faux la
france est en train de s'engager dans
une stratégie de que de quotas
d'immigration par par catégorie
professionnelle qui va dans le sens du
canada qui va avec comme comme comme le
font les grands pays comme le canada ou
aux états-unis ont saisi au canada on
s'installe pas comme ça on vient à sur
la base de deux d'un centre de bourg en
fonction des rejoint et que louis
dutriat ça a été votée c'est une loi qui
était votée par nicolas sarkozy avec
l'hexagone a été mise en oeuvre il l'a
mis en oeuvre deux ans après s'est rendu
compte que ça avec soin mais on sait
qu'en de trop de danger un appel
la crise de 2008 il a relancé mais donc
la loi elle existe est aujourd'hui il ya
la liste des métiers sous tension
donc franchement c'est pas d'une immense
nouveauté non c'est pas de nouveauté
mais si on commence à l'elysée fait des
choses nouvelles
annan ancien mot nous renouveler on a
sincèrement que certains principes de la
boîte à idées dans la classe lors ils
appellent ça maintenant l'heure de vie
de classe je crois dans les lycées c'est
à dire que les élèves s'expriment chacun
de se voir mettre des petits papiers
dans une boîte à idées
puis après on jette la boîte à idées une
fois qu'on a oublié tout juste il à pied
on doit être aux choses sérieuses on a
l'impression que les français sont un
petit peu pris pour des écoliers
les français ont été pris par des
écoliers ou par des comme des imbéciles
par l'ensemble des présidents précédents
puisque personne n'a donné les chiffres
exacts de l'immigration sa part fois
qu'un président dans les colonnes de
valeurs actuelles en plus va donner les
chiffres très précis à l'unité près
souvenez-vous du nombre de deux services
de permis de séjour ont été délivrés en
france et du nombre de candidats à
l'asile politique en france à l'unité
près donc pour une fois on a au moins la
transparence on à la transparence on a
la possibilité de débattre sereinement
essayez essayons de le faire de manière
d idéologisé que ce soit à droite où on
pense que l'immigration est une
profession et à gauche où on pense qu'il
faut ouvrir toutes les barrières non
simplement essayant d'être raisonnable
et de voir effectivement
quels sont les besoins de l'est du pays
en matière d'immigration parce qu'il ya
un besoin sur le plan démographique et
sur le plan du travail
et puis il ya des réalités qu'il faut
gérer quoi voilà les maires haute il
était entendu par emmanuel macron et
bien
au risque de vous décevoir mon cher
brice donc les tweets une autre
ce qu'ils veulent sur twitter le compte
le point de vue répondre non à 73% la
france rurale et périphériques votre
plus que les citadins ça emmanuel macron
doit le savoir
c'est ce qu'observe citoyens payeurs
avec internautes fidèles puisque il
commentait déjà le discours du président
et merci de nous rejoindre et bien